Relógios e anéis inteligentes podem
ajudar a melhorar a saúde? E como usar
as informações de forma eficiente? Bem,
antes de falar das informações desses
dispositivos, eu queria falar um
pouquinho sobre a polêmica de que esses
dispositivos podem causar alguns agravos
à saúde. Eles podem de fato oferecer
benefícios para monitoramento, mas
alguns estudos recentes revelam
potenciais riscos que tem que ser levado
em consideração. Infelizmente a gente
não tem as respostas
definitivas, mas é importante o uso
equilibrado desses dispositivos. Então,
hoje nós sabemos que os smartwhes e
também os dispositivos na forma de anel
emitem radiação de campos
eletromagnéticos, seja através da
conexão Bluetooth ou Wi-Fi. Então, muita
gente considera que os níveis são
considerados
seguros, isso pelos padrões
internacionais, mas alguns estudos
sugerem que a exposição prolongada pode
causar efeitos adversos. Então, a
radiação eletromagnética, né, conhecida
pela sigla EMF, poderia potencialmente
restringir o fluxo sanguíneo na região
do pulso e pode levar em algumas pessoas
mais sensíveis a dor de cabeça, fadiga
ocular e náusea, que também tem um
efeito interessante desses dispositivos.
Fizeram estudos psicológicos e
comportamentais para identificar
consequências do uso desses dispositivos
wearables, né? Existe um estudo da
Universidade da Carolina do Norte com
172 pacientes que tinham fibrilação
atrial. E foi demonstrado nesse estudo
que os usuários dos dispositivos
vestíveis, né, ou wearles, apresentaram
maiores taxas de ansiedade sobre os
sintomas cardíacos e maior utilização de
recursos de saúde. Ou seja, a pessoa
fica pilhada porque tá monitorando o
tempo todo aquele parâmetro e fica muito
ansiosa. Existe o estresse por
autoimização. Então, o monitoramento
constante pode levar uma pressão
psicológica quando os dados não estão
ideais, estão mostrando declínio. Isso
cria uma linha tênue entre o estilo de
vida saudável e uma sensação aí de ter
que otimizar constantemente os
parâmetros, tá? Então, pode levar esse
stress também.
Então, o uso 24 horas por dia, 7 dias da
semana, pode levar em algumas pessoas
mais suscetíveis ao estresse, ao
esgotamento mental e físico. Isso pode
impedir a regeneração necessária dessa
pessoa. Existe também relatos de
impactos no sono. Usuários regulares do
Smartwatch frequentemente experimentam
problemas de sono, tá? Especialmente
quando usam o dispositivo antes de
dormir. Por quê? A luz azul emitida
pelas telas pode dificultar o
desligamento cerebral. Então, é
recomendado desligar a tecnologia 2 a 3
horas antes de dormir. Alguns estudos
também relatam perda de memória,
alterações de humor devido à privação de
sono causada pelo uso prolongado. Então,
olha que coisa paradoxal, certo? A
constante disponibilidade de
notificações poderia diminuir a
produtividade e criar uma dependência
tecnológica. Aí tem a questão também dos
químicos, das substâncias presentes nos
dispositivos. Existe os químicos
chamados químicos eternos, porque não se
degradam, né, que é o
PFAS. Então, a pesquisa que foi
realizada recentemente na Universidade
de Notridame descobriu níveis
significativos de um produto chamado
ácido
perfluoxano nas pulseiras de smartwatch.
Especialmente, olha a paradoxalidade, ó,
especialmente modelos mais caros acima
de 30. Então, esses químicos eternos
poderiam ser absorvidos pela pele
durante o uso prolongado, concentrações
superiores a 16.000 partes por bilhão em
alguns produtos, que é muito acima do
partes por bilhões encontrado em
cosméticos. Tem alguns riscos médicos
específicos, por exemplo, comportamentos
mal adaptativos. Ocorre que alguns dados
imprecisos ou incompletos dos wearables
podem levar comportamentos prejudiciais
à saúde como exercícios excessivos ou
manejo inadequado de condições médicas.
Aí seria um problema mais relacionado à
falta
de precisão de alguns desses
dispositivos.
Então, indivíduos que têm condições
cardíacas podem receber falsas garantias
de dispositivo com limitações de
detecção. Também temos exacerbações de
transtornos existentes. Então, pesquisas
preliminares sugere que os vestíveis ou
rarbles podem agravar transtornos
alimentares com participantes relatando
que os positivos afetaram negativamente
os comportamentos alimentares
desordenados. Então vamos agora aos
contrapontos dos benefícios que são
observados, tá? a perspectiva médica
positiva desses wearbles. Muitos médicos
continuam recomendando esses smartwatchs
para monitoramento de métricas, como é o
caso de frequência cardíaca, saturação
de oxigênio e padrão de sono,
especialmente para pacientes com
arritmias ou apneia, mesmo que tenha
esse risco de aumento de ansiedade.
Então, durante o período do C19, os
dispositivos conseguiram
detectar a doença até 2,7 dias antes dos
testes laboratoriais, né, segundos
alguns estudos. E existe muita gente
falando que a exposição à radiação
eletromagnética do Smartws seria muito
menor ou significativamente menor que a
dos smartphones. E os estudos atuais
indicam que esses dispositivos poderiam
ser seguros. Então tem essa polêmica aí
se é seguro ou não essa parte
eletromagnética. Mas vamos então para a
parte prática. O que que eu recomendo
para vocês? Então, caso vocês tenham
esses dispositivos e queiram utilizá-los
para
monitoramento, estratégia de mitigação.
Então, use o modo avião quando o
monitoramento ativo não é necessário.
Remova o dispositivo periodicamente para
prevenir a irritação da
pele. Escolha pulseiras de silicone de
baixo custo em vez de pulseiras mais
sofisticadas que t os fluoelastômeros.
Desligar notificações durante o sono,
focar em tendências de longo prazo em
vez de medições pontuais. Cuidado com
isso. Ao mesmo efeito a pessoa que fica
se medindo o todos os dias em relação a
peso e pessoas que têm transtorno de
ansiedade são muito pilhadas ou
transtornos alimentares ou tendências
obsessivo compulsivas devem evitar usar
esse tipo de dispositivo, porque podem
ficar pior ainda do ponto de vista
psicológico. ou ainda pode até usar mais
com monitoramento médico e psicológico.
Então, concluindo, a evidência atual
sugere que, embora os smartwatchs podem
ter benefícios substanciais para
monitoramento, o uso tem que ser
equilibrado com consciência dos
potenciais riscos. Tem que ser um uso
consciente, personalizado, reconhecendo
que diferentes indivíduos podem ter
diferentes respostas a informações ou
até mesmo a exposição eletromagnética
até substâncias que possam ser liberadas
dessas pulseiras. Eu sei que é uma
resposta complexa, você queria ouvir uma
resposta muito mais simples, mas é o que
temos para hoje, né? Você tem que
avaliar prós e contras aí para usar
esses dispositivos.